I'm currently staying at home for
Christmas which means I'm staying in my
old room which has basically been
completely unchanged since when I went
to uni I asked you on Twitter and you
were interested so though we do a quick
room tour one of the very first things
you'll notice when you come in the room
is the planes so these are all World War
two planes that's like an Avro Lancaster
that's Hawker hurricane that's an ultra
marine Spitfire they were all built by
me and my dad they're all Airfix kit and
my dad was in the Navy so when I was a
kid I wouldn't seem a huge amount could
be on ship a lot when he was home we do
these FX kids so I like to keep them up
as like a reminder of us building and
painting them together so pass the place
take you on a tour of the gross scale
structure of the room we've got
captain's bed here so there's like
shelving underneath because it's not a
huge room but I'm an only child so when
when it comes to space the bed sheets
believe it or not were bed sheets that I
bought for myself when I was at uni in
my first year they actually glow in the
dark it's they're really cool we've also
got shelving books that's actually a
wardrobe as a desk which has actually
got work on it which I'm trying to avoid
and then that's kind of it you will
notice as well there's lots of posters
on the wall so these that one was like
I've actually been asked about this lots
you might recognize this in my earliest
videos I had the camera like here and I
shot facing this way so these these
posters have been completely unchanged
this one everyone asks about it was
actually free with the independent the
newspaper so I don't know where you can
get that anymore but if that's even
possible but same glows yeah same goes
and I glow-in-the-dark
star map which also came in independent
that used to be up here on the ceiling
as did these I actually had about or
maybe 20 at these revision posters they
will all feel like GCSE and a-level
science and maths and they was they all
go on the ceiling so that when I was in
bed I could like lie in bed and pretend
I was revising it kind of work because
they suits into my head so I lit them
every day so there's still a few
revision posters like different types of
telescopes there's actually one still on
the ceiling which is the cosine law
there's also two things from the ox
talent awards which are these technology
awards that they give out in Oxford
which I've won a couple of and that's
from Durrell this conservation charity
I've been very involved with that was an
Alaska
I and then and then we get to the
unashamed geekery because in here and up
here are some of my collection of
Warhammer and Lord of the Rings
miniatures so I collected and painted
what have quite a long time I actually
have a whole case down here of an army
there's lots of other ring stuff this is
like my display cabinet oh I think my
best matches are along with this guy
here we have one of lots of bookcases in
the house this is my one which is full
of mostly my books and like VHS is
because I'm that old
including my nativity tape from 1997
where I play the first wise man if I can
find the method I think this might be a
cool subscriber like goal to reach like
a million or maybe a hundred thousand
let's be realistic subscribers if I can
get the footage off of this as me it's
the first wise man I'll see what I could
be this is my granny's I don't know if
you can actually makeup detail on this
so this was my granny's edition of Pride
and Prejudice which was given to her
when she left school not even be a date
yes December 1939 most of Pride and
Prejudice actually read from this until
it started falling apart at by 9:00
coffee a note on Teddy by the way so
Teddy was my first birthday present when
I was a year old when I was year old he
was given to me by mom and dad
and apparently first thing I did was I
unwrapped him and I hugged him and
that's basically what I've been doing
ever since so when I come home I still
have him in the bed because I'm a
massive softy so next up I actually
haven't looked in here for a long time
this is my wardrobe which has actually
been co-opted by mum so yeah those
dresses and things they're not mine up
here we've got like photos and stuff
this was bought for my granddad when I
was a kid and really made me kind of
keep going into science
that's my fossil collection fun I want
to be a paleontologist these are my neck
juice when I was a scout so if you
weren't in scouts you can tell what
troop a scout was in from there
neckerchief which is this thing so this
is mine this was the 10th berth with our
Woggle yes that's actually what it's
called
and I've also got a few others this one
I traded cuz I had two of my neck Chiefs
so when I went to Switzerland to the
International Scout Center
this was one from the north of Italy I
think it was a little kid who I traded
with and then this one was a special one
from them went to Switzerland in fact if
I have a look in here yeah so that's my
Explorer uniform I've worn this for
quite a while we do not see too many
badges although you all know that I did
over 150 nights away and we did we did
basically everything that like
associated with Divi apart from the
formal structure like you basically name
an outdoor activity and we did it I also
found my shirt for the last day of
school look this is this is written on
blood my mate uh hang on I can't really
show him a back but it's also covered
it's just occurred to me that I would
have worn this last in 2007 when I did
my GCSEs uh and then next to with that
painting supplies uh oh there's actually
a PDF of this online somewhere so if I
can find that I'll put it in the
description it's not very good I warn
you but it did get one of the very first
a stars in the country and then there's
these you have to remember that when I
was a kid and we didn't have smartphones
or after that so these were like my
favorite toys and their little 10 Thomas
the Tank Engine models this one's Edward
got like James you've got all the
classics in here but diesel Henry I've
also got the oh jeez Thomas Annie and
Clarabel I can't believe how much
entertainment lucky gal just making
trains are these things dad and I were
both big fans of trains like almost like
a kind of you know copy dinner
everywhere when I was kid then lastly
coming over to the desk I've got a whole
bunch of stuff on this wall
this was the my mop from the first set
of videos I made for some Peter's
College YouTube channel some of these I
didn't actually end up making but this
was like the first time I properly
thought about video making so it's kind
of like a relic this was when I went to
Space Camp at the Kennedy and Johnson
Space Center's with lots of people
who've signed it you can just about make
it out now this just when I flew to
California as an undergrad this was the
single greatest piece of criticism I've
ever received and it's where I keep it
pinned up on the wall that was when I
did ten to thirty five miles over
Dartmoor in two days this was from the
trip to Switzerland with all my mates
this was when I won an award at a Model
UN conference these were some of my
campaign posters for head boy which for
some reason worked you know the funny
thing is somebody actually asked me how
on earth
the birds to sit on me no joke this is
frankly a mess but includes these
tickets the game today which oh my god
that was nearly 10 years ago that was
some custom note paper we made for the
Model UN is Columbia my 6 1 levers thing
when I went we're watching in California
a cappella ball my friend David brought
me this from New Zealand when he did his
undergrad work there actually David who
just got married to Rachel boyfriends
mine Congrats guys if you're a longtime
viewer you might remember this this was
from when I went to the AG you last year
and we went to the California Academy of
Sciences
after the speaking competition only one
night I got some funding for the raw
Meteorological Society my JCR photo from
the last year was in college and then
this lot um you know this was the group
of us who did debating in school we were
really unusual in that we were from a
state school we had no debate coaches
per se but mr. Backhouse Harry Backhouse
please if you're watching this sent me
an email because I'd really love to get
in touch with you and then they across
the middle there next to me it's Sally
Cartwright who very sadly passed away a
couple of years ago from a brain tumor
very suddenly I like to keep this up
because it reminds me those two teachers
and we were really good at what we did
debating considering we had no coaching
at all and then past all the classic
video games that's a picture of dad and
me from when he was a Supply Officer I
think this was HMS beaver possibly the
least intimidating name for a warship
ever but I thought it was cool I mean
look at my face you don't miss think I
was in command of a warship look at a
smug I am and that's kind of it like I
say it's not a very big room but thank
you very much for watching um thank you
all so I don't you have a happy holidays
one thing I've had a really rest for a
couple of days though if you're seeing
this I'm back in Exeter and editing and
working so actually getting towards my
thesis I'm supervising if you're
watching I hope you've had a happy
holidays and thank you for making my end
of 2016 absolutely mad like my audience
on YouTube has just exploded then I
refuse I'm getting on this kind of
videos just never never ever would have
expected to be getting tens of thousands
of views on videos that I make on like a
weekly basis so whoo thank you for
watching thank you for being awesome and
I'll see you next year